i don't like being in the tub as i get
older man i don't like it as much
man also i used to when i was young it's
fun to lay in a tub and look at your
body
you know it's not as much fun as i get
older
you know that you know what that's a
fair point right there that's why i put
like two bath bombs in and
you can't see that i get out of the tub
once it starts to dissipate and i'm like
what is that
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
yeah i think so because uh when you i
don't know which way you came but when
you pulled in
do you see the line of people from
[ __ ]
that's just the old people waiting to
get the vaccine
oh i don't think it goes down the
freaking blood just just
heaven's doorstep well good for them
yeah good for them
they need to i think they're trying to
expand yeah
the amount of people no no not the
vaccine they're trying to expand
who can actually administer it that's
the real problem oh
it's not that they don't have enough
it's that they don't have people they're
under the guidelines they don't have
people qualified
to give that exact stick down yeah so
there you go check out everything it
could be like
walmart cvs yeah let cvs get on yeah
yeah
they got it look dude out here in
tennessee katniss everdeen will give you
that [ __ ] bro they got people just
yeah fire there dog really got people
giving
[Laughter]
people giving that thing however they
want out here man it's getting
wild bro i don't even know what's going
on outside yeah but when you leave just
take a left and you will see
just oldies just silver here down the
block so it's like voting they taking up
a lot of time they
you know it could be faster but these
old and they don't and they're patient
it's cold out then my parents already
got it oh really
yeah pull that up well they i think that
because they had extras
because you know they have if they don't
use it they gotta throw it away so when
when the
front line workers don't take it because
a lot of them don't want to take it
which is crazy
yeah then they go they call uh senior
living places
oh and that's where your parents are at
yeah oh damn yeah so they got your
parents are in senior living eric
yeah my parents are in like this
independent living place
you know all the rich and famous got it
already
what the famous people you know justin
timberlake had it already
i heard sean penn got i have no problem
with that
no no what are you gonna do yeah he
employs a lot of people
yeah what are you gonna do i mean the
man makes great music
what do you do how are we supposed to
decide i heard sean penn has it
as well he got the vaccinations
obviously he got the he got the
vaccination and that haitian dude i
heard he got it from um
some 41 or something always that band
with the
haitians why cliff john nobody was like
john
refugees my bad yeah the refugees
[Laughter]
i look like before and after being a
little [ __ ] that's what y'all look like
really who's that's where we're gonna go
yeah you look like i'm not even like you
talking [ __ ] from like a sequester jail
cell right now so i don't even wanna
yeah the last setup i've seen this
shitty was r kelly yeah
you look like he looks like snowden
like like he's in like ecuador or some
place
because he'll get arrested if he can sit
in california where you're located
it was going to be little wayne then
theo to get the trump party
[Laughter]
he was [ __ ]
[Applause]
they're making a tv show with nicholas
cage playing uh joe exotic before
what happens on tiger king it's about
him when he's growing up i'm trying to
get on the uh
how is nicholas cage who's 85
gonna play cgi when he's young i don't
understand that yeah
like joe pesci i don't think it's a good
idea to have somebody like nicholas cage
who already has like a reputation of
like craziness yeah we and
we'll just play somebody cause all we're
gonna see is nicholas cage yeah you're
right i'm not gonna see tiger king i
can't suspend my disbelief i'm gonna see
is this a nicolas cage documentary also
how how how hard are we gonna squeeze
this tiger king thing oh i've seen it
i'm all set man we know how it ends yeah
yeah
but you didn't cast dak shepard
well uh yeah no i don't know but yeah i
know nicholas cage is playing
is playing joe exotic um
what do you think do you think that it
was trump was close to pardoning tiger
king or you think there was no chance
you guys have any intel on that
they said he was thinking about it they
brought it up at the meetings and [ __ ]
who knows wait
but this guy who had a button for diet
coke first of all
i want to be at that meeting like did
they have a
like a vision board up and it was like
lil wayne is up there
kodak black yeah yeah like who's like
all the old white people were like yeah
and they were just like how did they
decide
how did he even come up i don't even
understand how they i don't do you
really think
it was trump that came up with these
lists his son came up with it
wow his son's kind of well there you go
in the known and brought up
joe exotic and then i think trump was
like all right well think about it
did they really think about it like they
had some good cards at the end though
remember they had uh
i mean trump tried at the end he tried
he got little wayne to vouch for him
because little man was trying to get a
pardon obviously so there was a
trade-off going on there that's obvious
i feel like
but the kodak black one's weird well
that's how you get the streets back too
you know what i mean what you mean yeah
oh yeah you're getting kicked out office
he was like this
little wayne you know what i mean so
they like him right
he's going to be in the next video
that's probably the yeah right lil wayne
cat williams
yeah why not he should have got r kelly
out
if you really want to be this is what
he's this is what he tweeted he could
tweet from jail
oh he has someone tweet for him oh i was
too innocent and too gay
well i only mattered junior when he
needed to make a comment about me to
boost his social media post
boy we're all stupid to believe he
actually stood for equal justice his
corrupt friends all come first
this dude didn't even verify this is
this could be some idiot with a [ __ ]
pitcher
no it's him it's he he's he has
something you don't know that it's him
brendan you don't know that it's him
you guys aren't following him i'm
surprised
it seems right on brand for you guys
[Laughter]
theo had his like business partner on
his show
what what who was that who who's the
tiger dude you got on your show theo
oh wasn't the manager guy the guy that
was running the place that guy was cool
though that's a cool dude
oh no no you had the other guy on what
was it yeah we had doc annal
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they're all
a little too into time
no this guy no theo had the the mormon
type cult leader guy who was
[ __ ] this guy yeah he had like seven
yeah
you said the whole time fear was like
and so then you did what
and then the tiger would cost how much a
year exactly look at it and then you got
his son on too huh
yeah yeah sun is dope man they're both
dope actually i think they run a good
outfit over there if you want to do
something
you want to make a sexy video
everybody's been over there shaq's been
over there
russell simmons undertaker you don't
know that
everybody was in the video in the
interview the whole time deal
queen latifa's been over there
we have a stan king and a sting crew has
a standing invite to go to doc andel's
reservation his 22
room mansion in south carolina surprised
and stay at his
mansion yeah with all the wild animals
and [ __ ] yeah
what what city is it in uh some places
one of the carolinas i don't know i'm
surprised kid rock's 50th birthday
wasn't at
that seems right in the line
[Laughter]
this will make you happy dog look what i
brought for your [ __ ] ass
lay that money out let me tell you eric
let me teach you a little something
cause i know that's your son right there
with you
what i'm telling you is your son right
now
is paying me a thousand dollars because
he bets against
un-american legend mr dustin the diamond
poirier baby he he he bet bettered
against him
and he lost i lost i told you it's gonna
be a close fight though i told you
it was even money though is this
fighting talk okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
this male toxicity yeah oh you don't
like the fights
eric no miss i i don't like violent
sports like that i just you watch
football
i know football is the only violent
sport i watch but even when something
violent happens i'm like oh turn up
yeah i just look when i see what
happened when i see muhammad ali in his
later years
yeah i see that and i know that it's
directly related to
boxing yeah i just think to myself is
was this worth it
like all those guys man when you see
them when you like amanda holyfield and
all these guys when they talk
and it's just their faces all messed up
and i go was this worth it if you had to
deal with i deal with on a weekly basis
from fighters call me who have problems
from ctu that's what i'm saying right so
i just i can't
i can't we're like we're one step away
from them signing a waiver that they
could be killed in the ring
i mean it's just we're so close to that
i just i i don't like it you do not deal
with any of it like movies tv shows you
don't like anything i know the movies
are fake so that's different what about
300 would you watch it or are you gonna
just close your eyes
that's a good point listen i just said i
was against fake violence i'm against
what about my girl when a boy gets stung
by the bees
[Laughter]
can you handle it or you shut it down
you know i thought i thought i missed
theo
[Laughter]
what about up when the balloons take the
house away what are you doing here
hey you're looking you know you cried at
the beginning don't act like you
didn't move what about in seoul when he
fell into the pothole
yeah yeah i didn't have you do you know
you look like here we go
i'm so tired of this like oh really
hundreds of messages on instagram i mean
like your new movie you look good in
this i'm like oh my god but you could
play the off-broadway live play
you could be the main character way off
bro but this was weird to me i didn't
know what
it was about until like then it turned
into like a death movie and i was like
oh this is weird yeah my son was like
what is happening i'm like yeah i don't
know dude let's put on nick at night
yeah we just said that because it was
like is he black why are they doing a
movie
why is it why are all of them black yeah
yeah because they're not used to that in
disney
yeah no not at all but i want to ask you
this so eric a lot of this
there's a definitely a big push nowadays
if you see commercials or television or
uh even drawings where a lot of there's
a lot more black
artists and black performers
entertainers um
working these days suddenly every
commercial everybody's mixed in it and
they both brush in their teeth and
everybody's black
you know but what i'm saying is do you
know do you notice more work for you
these days like uh
no because they know some diversity they
don't yeah that's a different
they don't go mixed race they don't go
ambiguous race but when i see that
but by the way i was talking about this
too because when i see this
it just seems so transparent like it's
hard to get past
so many years of everything being white
and so then when you finally now you
have it mixed you kind of go
what's going on here yeah why are they
doing this yeah yeah you know
so we'll get used to it it'll be it'll
just be commonplace and we won't think
about it
or was your mom my mom's my mom looks
more like me my mom's fair-skinned
you know but and i but i have an aunt my
aunts look like oprah yeah you know i
mean i have i have a wide range of um
uh y'all got that buffet bro
yeah the look at that real buffet you
know so it is what it is
i mean i wish i wish i would get more
work
now have you thought of darkening up a
little
i'm talking about getting the sun a
little thin a little tanner darkening
what what what would that be because
charlemagne was darker
you know what this reminds me of this
reminds me of i remember doing a
a commercial audition many years ago
when i first started in the business
and the guy said to me after the
audition he goes can you um
maybe do it do it more hmm
urban urban and i was like i said
black you want it more black you know
and he was like yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know like you got it but you got a
bowl of weed in front of you and you go
swear to god swear to god i'd never
forget that that's what theo just did
but you know i'm gonna do that you gotta
think of blacking it up i think you'll
play yeah
you're everything going darker
charlemagne from breakfast club went the
opposite way he was really dying
he got got money and got lighter he get
white move
oh he will be asian about in about six
years
without well that'll be in it well they
just had they had their thing well
schultz might take his darkness schultz
might get darker
oh schultz is that dark hunter bro he
will really uh
he'll [ __ ] take your darkness while
you're sleeping dude deal what are you
gonna do with this money dog what are
you gonna do with the grand
with that granddaughter try sniffing it
daddy
let me think what i like to do bro might
get my face done
or something like get a little botox
bruh all right botox
why don't you but once you buy some of
uh dustin poury's hot sauce a thousand
dollars worth of his hot sauce they
don't have to fight anymore
you know what i already i already have
about 150 worth down downstairs right
now
uh let me think what i'll do you know
what i'm gonna do man i'm gonna buy i'm
gonna donate 500
to the good fight foundation right now
so i'll put that out there
and then the other 500 i might give me a
couple of
necklaces from kohl's i still got this
so you still got five hundred and forty
five dollars left
so yeah yeah that's not gonna say that
too much yeah what's your father
what necklace is you gonna get that coal
going to
cause sleeping on coals fine jewelers
bro you guys got to get over there man
oh man we got to get you we got to get
you back to l.a yeah that house real
vibe man
y'all sleeping on cold babies
and they got jewelry for the whole
family man i'm telling you something
right now and i'll tell you straight up
a lot of times hydration is you don't
think about it
you don't think that your body's 95
water 96
water you never think about it so you do
something and you don't have as much
water in your body you got 70
water you're like damn you know larry's
looking a little shorter than usual
that's because you got low tide brother
you got to stay hydrated
and what really keeps me helpful and
hydrated is liquid iv
when i'm feeling down and i don't have
time to go get an actual iv
liquid iv is the one empty the packet
into the cup
get the water stir it with a spoon i
like to stir mine for a while so it
really mixes good
it's liquid iv's energy multiplier
that also helps when you need a boost do
you have a favorite flavor they got all
the flavors
this and that that and this berry
everything orange
the boost you get from one to two cups
of coffee without the crash that's what
comes
with the liquid iv energy multiplier a
mixture of matcha
guayasa and gengar that's high in
antioxidants
helps improve mood and focus liquid iv
is on a mission to positively change
the world the company has donated over
6.7 million servings globally
grab your energy liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 percent off when you
go to liquidity.com
and use promo code kats at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you use promo code kats at liquidity.com
liquidiv.com start fueling your
adventures
today at liquid iv.com
promo code k-a-t-s
all right you have a hard time taking
pills so do i i've been there
i've been hard and i've not been hard
you know i got that penis like soil you
know you never know sometimes you're
going
you're gonna hit rock and sometimes
you're just gonna be able to dig forever
and that's
got that soft that you know that baby
bread
but what i'm telling you is that you can
change it with chewables from blue chew
they can be taken on a full or empty
stomach you can swim if you want doesn't
matter
it only takes a few minutes to connect
with bluechew.com
an affiliated physician and if you
qualify
you get prescribed online quickly no
in-person doctor visit no awkward
conversation
no waiting in line at a pharmacy ships
directly
to your door in discreet packaging the
chewables from bluechew.com are made in
the usa
and you and your partner will love it
because if you get hard they get it they
get they get a heart
they get your heart on so they get
served out
here's a great deal for you guys visit
bluechew.com get your
first order free when you use promo code
kats
just pay five dollar shipping that's b l
u e c
h e w dot com promo code
k-a-t-s oh i gotta send you my text too
nick that brent that uh dustin sent me
well that was a that was a nice flex
right there
oh they're tight they're tight i want to
have michael chandler and dustin poirier
in the next this past weekend hopefully
calling in
here's what i got at sunday at 2 54 a.m
it said tell brennan b-r-e-n-n-a-n
he owes you well he's in dubai hasn't
slept he knows how to spell my name
no i don't think look and dustin will be
the first one to tell you
spelling name really is [ __ ] you know
his forte
you know but he said tell brennan he
said tell brennan he owes you some cash
maybe that's what he said
you bet against yeah yeah why'd you bet
again that's a great question eric thank
you
why'd you bet against somebody i'm
closer because you were so confident on
it
i wasn't that confident i kept telling
theo i was like doug
if you're going to bet on this not bad a
bet on dustin because vegas has it three
to one this is a good fight man
conor hasn't fought but you bet him yeah
that's because it's fun for the show
i actually wanted better more too and i
was like i'll bring cash down whatever
you want to do
all right so you have no i appreciate
the bet that seems like a soft answer
right there that seems like a
backpedaling answer yeah a little bit
just say you think he's a [ __ ] just say
it
just say it right to just write on
camera put it out there
zuma man zoom in right now you didn't
think he had it in him anymore
no it was crazy dude did he he seemed
angry after the fight did you
you sense that a little bit brendan yeah
i think so
the the disrespect right like they're
like oh we fight chandler next he's like
god what are we doing he's like chance
to be the guy i already beat you know
how
the you look at my body of work it's
like give me the goddamn belt
and he's not getting paid like the guys
that he's fighting right so he fought
khabib
khabib made more money than god poured
he lost that fight but got paid [ __ ] he
fights connor
carter makes more money than god dustin
gets [ __ ] over there again so
i think he's just sick of it well i mean
yeah i agree but don't you but isn't it
the business
isn't that the entertainment portion of
it that this there's no fairness in it
conor mcgregor's the name whoever he
fights is going to make a lot of money
right there's yes so there's there's
fairness
within it's same as comedy like there's
market value
so how many tickets you sell on the road
is how much money you're getting i know
i know but i'm not saying so okay
that's a good review i don't know but
that's why he makes more money i know
but that's a good example
because what this guy is saying is i'm
funnier than that guy
i'm clearly a better comedian but the
market value is this other guy
yeah they're saying you might be better
right right that's what i'm saying more
exactly to see this guy right we're
going to pay this guy so
so he's so that's what i'm saying is he
needs to understand that it doesn't work
about
like people don't get paid based off
their skill value they get paid based
off like
whatever the thing is yeah it it and
it's kind of a shame because
you know the ufc is a sport because in
the nfl or nba
you know if you're the best player in
the game you're gonna be compensated
like the best player
yeah yeah right yeah in the ufc you're
talking about or even for that
[ __ ] yeah but then does that mean they
don't get paid but does that mean that
ufc is not
um it's not run say
it's based more on that than it is like
like like a a
fair and equitable way of doing it right
yeah that's the reason
it's like there's a league and it's like
you have seatings and it's like if you
have this thing to do though like
like dustin poirier is ranked number two
connor's number four because they care
about that
no not really yeah that's what it's more
random like the wwe shouldn't it be like
a tournament like it starts there should
be a fight season
and then it's like you fight a certain
number of fights for the entire year and
then it's like oh we have the number one
seed that versus this and then they have
a pot at the end of the year
they do that in uh world series or what
was it pfl the pfl does that on the espn
prize nobody i've never even heard of it
so that's why it's not there you go i
was just going to say nobody knows what
that is
watching this [ __ ] that sounds like like
this it's bad like the filipino league
or something it just doesn't seem i
think he also said you know that they
had two weeks where they were
just sitting there stuck in that place
man that must have been we got a
quarantine he can't leave the room
yeah and then you know and then it's
it's the people with this on the island
yeah
abu dhabi but the island's great what a
good idea they can't leave though
i mean the island's not this city block
i'm sure it's
well no they can't they can't even go
out they can't leave their hotel room
oh they're like stuck in there yeah but
how much money did he get
750 i thought i saw well still plus he
get a bonus
so he'll he'll make he'll make over a
mill okay so for a million dollars you
can stay in your hotel room for a few
years
right yeah you know it's not like cry me
a river yeah
13.50 an hour
he working at kohl's in tennessee you
know what i mean in the face so you got
a little oh this is great bro
but hey man i think they got to give the
man the belt who else is he going to
fight you know what i'm saying get
pay the mandana pay the man
[Laughter]
uh let's see this cats fan he was pretty
hyped uh when
dustin got to finish come on baby
he's shirtless
[Music]
wow you can't have your shirt on and
[ __ ] love dustin diamond poirier i'm
gonna go ahead and say that right now
bro
okay i was completely naked by the end
of the fight
yeah and i watch it at a bar and you
know what on behalf of king in this
thing i'm gonna take that thousand i'm
gonna donate the whole thing to good
fight foundation man i'm sorry for being
cheap bro
let's let's go like i'm gonna donate 200
that doesn't story foundation
let's get rocky out here fam look we got
everybody getting these [ __ ] vaccines
we don't know who's gonna make it who
gonna sprout a [ __ ] clitoris off
their back we don't know
nobody knows what are you one of those
you want to know you think you'll get
gills
you want to know they just made this
[ __ ] in three months bro where they been
making it at
the lab the same place the virus came
due to the entire world
science the entire smartest minds in the
world
in the world came together we needed to
work on this i think they can figure it
out
i'm gonna trust them i hope they can
yeah yeah and not i hope they can but
i'll tell you everything
will be the first round of people to try
it out bro okay
well the first rounds out the first
teams out outside the door here
yeah they're getting the same people
that are affected by
covet the most right the ones getting
the vaccine first so we can kind of see
yeah you know let's test it out right
now with
people's grandma that's how they doing
it right now yeah that is what they're
doing bro
there's a lot of looking at that nana
how you doing
actually feel pretty good all right if
we hear her go hey
[Laughter]
yeah i'm waiting for the third batch man
that's what i'm waiting for
i hope i get a tail out of it though i
don't give a [ __ ] have you heard about
the vaccine chasers there's like young
kids like you said they throw
them out at the end of the day if they
don't fill them all so there's young
people going to like
vaccine centers that are in like under
privileged areas and just like camping
out until the end of the day like hoping
they get it and it's like working so
like
kids in their 20s are getting the
vaccine they just want to get immune so
yeah
but they're literally yeah yeah but i
hope that
i hope it's not like you know they're
standing outside and the dude comes out
he throws it in the dumpster that's
exactly and then these people like
let's go get it i hope the guy goes all
right vaccines you know i hope they're
doing it like that yeah that would be
cool
yeah yeah like a donut shop at the end
of the night right right don't you don't
just don't make me get them out of the
trash
if they just put me together you messed
up
we got to start getting some women
vaccinated because i will say this
and i'm going to be honest with you
brother a lot of women been
you can't even find a woman out there
nowadays you go door to door and all the
[ __ ] in hiding
you know what i'm saying then nobody
knows where the chicks are they hide and
they say
people say oh where the [ __ ] at and
people say i don't know
so what i'm saying is we got to get
these chicks vaccinated get them back
out there man it sounds like you're
trying to convince us to go gay
no brother saying we're going to lose
population bro whatever doug
uh let's get in some debate club right
what's up
right guys it's mr a teacher out here in
northern california
sitting in my classroom right now
figured i have a debate club for you
favorite book you ever read in high
school
personally my favorite that hitter that
og the original king and the sting
of mice and men big strong guy
little guy out there doing work together
hopefully with you two uh theo doesn't
take brendan to see the rabbits
okay we know who which one britain just
go ahead let me know what you think
long time fan really enjoy you guys you
guys make me laugh all the time
uh special shout out to kat my stepmom
who i call my mom the woman that raised
me
uh she's straight out of vietnam so a
lot of times you talk about that part of
your background i totally uh
totally resonate with that youtube
brandon i got two little boys same age
as you so i enjoy all those stories
wishing you guys all the best gang gang
buzz buzz
take me to see the wabbits do your
homework
do your homework look i'm gonna say this
out the gate man this man is a little
too
handsome bro no homo to be working at a
uh high school bro he said
oh he did say high school because it
looks like college
bro you got to be a little ugly to work
at this high school i think because
otherwise you're getting all the trouble
hooking up with the kids that's what i'm
saying this guy is
it's really you're going to cause a lot
of trouble bro you can't be handsome and
be teaching at a high school dude
you're right conflict of interest
it's crazy brothers handsome people
we had a teacher bro i don't remember it
like that me neither
no like i see these teachers that are
just slanging tits towards these kids
and that was we had miss garafola dude
and she used to have that brassiere that
like
locked the titties up you don't talk
about the brazier that was like it
started at the
neck bruh jordan
her chin can touch her titty like just
like that
her [ __ ] was locked the [ __ ] up
you could see on the back it had a
little padlock on it that [ __ ] was you
would never
no one was ever going to see her tits
you know god she was beautiful praise
god
uh so this question's favorite book in
high school now
what my question is i think high school
no no but i'm i'm wondering
for like reading for pleasure or reading
before
i think his thing was like curriculum
the that read but
i don't even remember anything or just
your favorite but i think that's what he
was asking for
oh yeah what do you mean you don't
remember any books bro y'all [ __ ]
dumb bro
yeah i know i don't remember the book
sorry i'm older than both of you all so
because they haven't really changed the
books
what's interesting is you know they make
you read the book name of the book bro i
don't know either one
of more books now way more than i did in
high school actually
in high school i read like a lot of
science fiction fantasy books for
pleasure like
the book i remember reading is dragon
lance i remember that's the first book i
read i picked up and i was like oh this
is great
i just read all of them i loved it yeah
it was the books they forced you to read
were never that
fun yeah it was like fahrenheit what was
that yeah
i remember like charlie in the chocolate
factory that was my jam
i might got a little bit into that rl
stein [ __ ]
goosebumps oh yeah these bumps dude that
was last year brendan when you got into
that
yeah deal we're talking about school why
don't you sit this round out huh
what what books did your mom make you
read deal he's all spiderman
thor no coupons
you know hey look let me tell y'all some
books cause y'all obviously sleeping
the scarlet letter bruh okay you had to
read that
brendan the cliff notes you had to read
those
okay second of all what about that book
how to eat fried worms that was a good
book you had to read as a child
one of my favorites jonathan livingston
seagull bro about a bird that [ __ ] um
did his best also what about um
what about uh my side of the mountain
one of the best books
ever as a kid type type in uh high
school books
nick they're still reading them today
they haven't changed the curriculum
it's all the same [ __ ] they need to
switch that [ __ ] up
until somebody decides that the book is
not good and then they get killed well
think about the history books
like we know the history that they teach
is full of [ __ ] oh yeah now the stuff is
really full of [ __ ] man
the great gatsby fire to kill a
mockingbird getting a little old
was good they needed more chicks in it
though
they did uh catcher in the rye
uh responsible for john lennon's death
yep that's what they say
[Music]
what else encyclopedias macbeth was
brutal
yeah they don't even have those anymore
encyclopedias you guys even
like who even goes to the library last
time
like a kid today homeless people went to
the library
never wait they're reading twilight in
school now
why the [ __ ] would they read twilight in
school i guess that's what they're doing
hogwarts all that [ __ ] is popular in
school now
i used to love the movie days when we
take a week to watch malcolm x
yeah i used to love that good old days
watching movies yeah dude they had a lot
of good books when we was kids man
my favorite was my side of the mountain
it was about a young man from new york
he caught a bird
and he went out there sounder remember
that book
hatchet that [ __ ] was tight the hatchet
was tight dude
up a list
you know what i notice about him he
takes s's off words that should have s's
and puts
s's on words that don't have s's
whatever man y'all's a couple huh it's
russell simmons
yeah but he goes you know russell
simmons he just said
he just said y'all a bunch of homo
[Laughter]
praise god baby and who's this freaking
diligent city worker right here this guy
who obviously has his [ __ ]
all of his paperwork what up
shaw what up deal nick chen culture
corner
i got a debate club for you right
oh before we get to that brendan am i
not
think enough for the thick boy bite game
no you in dog
let me know we're still reviewing
yourself
heavy equipment hitters
with that ac bluetooth radio
backup camera heater or them
on the ground larry the lock splitter
quitter labor hands
let me know buzz buzz
so operating heavy machinery or manual
that looks like your son eric that looks
like your son
so everyone's my son down prolific
i'm just i'm just out here
but i'm saying here's what i'm saying is
you could do blackface and not get in
trouble we would get in trouble
and let's be honest brenden
brennan did a little in his house that
one time for some reason once you just
go real dark
yeah he wanted me to come in here wesley
snipe style one day your racism is
showing out their national theo
i'm not saying that man i'm just saying
you can if you want to we can't
theo's got a paper bag next to his door
and he holds that up to make sure
how dark are you are you paper bag dark
dude he hung out with kid rock and he's
changed man yeah you're different now
man
we saw that in my life in a slow hill
the white party doug uh to answer guys
questions like
we're talking about bulldozers and [ __ ]
that'd be fun yeah like that's not even
cool like
so you're saying you want me to lift the
rocks myself yeah or be in like an
air conditioned with a radio and
bluetooth everything was dope let's see
like tunes knocking [ __ ] over
that what kind of dumb truck man yeah
listen to some shade and lifting the
rocks up with the machine
i say go hand bro i like hand to hand
type stuff i like stuff like uh
origami but with heavy paper like you
know so it's
harder for your hands or knitting with
like a 50 80 pound test yarn so it's
tougher for your finger so you build
some strength
hell yeah all right
all that was gay
whatever bruh darken up and come at me
fam
uh what is up tinging broadcast this is
ian coming at you from georgia here with
the debate club question for the culture
corner
cat chappelle what white people do we
have a smell
um tom segura mentioned this on your
mom's house podcast they talked about it
miss pat mentioned it on her podcast as
well is there some truth to this or is
it a cultural stereotype that's
persisted from generation to generation
i gotta know uh so weigh in on i debate
it also if you need somebody for the
culture corner let me know i just
graduated
i don't have a job and you guys don't
have enough straight white males on the
podcast anyways
young man very good point you're a
different color you'd probably be in
um he's saying that white people have a
certain smell or white people that use
wet wipes
he's asking if white people have a smell
oh
i don't know i do do we eric what do you
think
i i well
that's me you might be smelling chin
and nick's a certain kind of white he's
from wisconsin so they they're stinky
yeah nick smells like an indoor nick
smells like an indoor white i feel like
nick smells like indoor pool he's an
indoor white so he don't have to have
chlorine on him or nothing like that
he yeah nick's not like indoor white
somebody since like when you walk into
like your friend's uh
house like in high school or middle
school there there's a certain scent
about the maybe the food they cooked or
the deodorant or no
yes he's always different like if you
walk into the apartment
it's like oh yeah seven different
flavors i think this is just a silly
joke that's gone too far
i think my friends that are white do
smell different though because i'm broke
tell us more so do they say that maybe
we smell different
yeah you're just smelling like clean air
when you go
there's no kimchi there's no hot sauce
yeah
there's no we're not eating fish yeah
there ain't pig feet in the thing upside
down it's like that's all
like ribs and make fries you know
there's no incense burning
you know it's like so that's all that is
yeah but but even if you go to like
chinatown there's a distinct smell like
a heavy smell
yeah different cultures smell
differently man i think if you go into
like a
um a lot of indian people's house smells
it they smell real
spicy curry or they smell like uh
like maybe kind of towels maybe damp
towels
i think if you go by like a black
person's whenever i go to a black
person's house it smells real warm in
there or smell like a
bread maybe or like a slick or something
real slick
tread light there buddy yeah high school
or middle school he's uh from ethiopia
like straight off the boat ethiopia
and he always had it was weird i
remember i'd go over there to play
and he always had like raw meat in a
bowl just like hanging out
that's what i'm saying
yeah it was weird like oh [ __ ] all that
ethnic like
ethnic stuff like you know what i mean
like he it's like a wet market when you
go to like yeah
you know yeah it's just different in
different places the people
like i said some cultures they use
incense and they use like you know
they have certain that kind of stuff has
this there's some stinky white people
though
like the white like whiteboard is
definitely different they're stinking
everybody like a white dude with
dreadlocks you know he's stinky
well look i think also here's the thing
though i think every cult
a lot often times one culture will smell
different to another culture doesn't
matter who it is
yeah so i think sometimes you get some
cultures a little bit more like they
might smell a certain way
some people if they have a pet in their
house and the pet pees upstairs in the
guest bedroom
and you don't tell anybody you let them
stay over there for a week and
everything smells like piss
yeah that's not a white thing no that's
just no but that's everybody yeah that's
the end you know what i'm saying so
there's different you got a grandparent
they might have a smell
yes sometimes your grandmother stinks a
little yeah older but that's because
they get
older yeah my grandma's skin is rotten
they bones as well
she sweats you know what it is it's like
as you get older you lose your sense of
smell or you get used to it quick so i
don't care if it's
i'm learning that even myself i'm like i
gotta go well i gotta my girl makes me
take a shower every night
damn that's the rule no matter what you
weren't doing it that's racist bro
shower like you know
yeah an afternoon yeah whenever it's
yeah whatever yeah whatever
i don't have a schedule and then she
goes you need to take a shower every
night so then
you don't notice until you start to go
what are you talking about oh you know
what let me go
yeah you know what you just don't that's
racist i feel like man making somebody
take a shower every day
at her times it's a tight schedule yeah
i take it probably three four i'll take
four showers a week man
adult showers as opposed to
taking yeah you're taking a bath as a
grown man
what you say bastard i just moved i just
got my parents i got a nice
bathtub now so i'm in there lounging
really
yeah i love a good man i got bath bombs
i thought i'm suckers in there oh damn
riley dawg i see your feet sticking out
of the water yeah cause i'm so tall that
i have to like i have to bathe
two parts of my body at a time so i
start with the legs
i get the chest you jump in the tub too
i don't get in a tub bra my damn adult
eric uh sits down with first of all you
know theo's in the tub
how do you want to hear him he over here
[Laughter]
yeah he got the whole bath kit from
kohl's you know you in that tub
i don't like being in the tub as i get
older man i don't like it as much man
also i used to when i was young it's fun
to lay in a tub and look at your body
you know it's not as much fun as i get
older
you know that you know what that's a
fair point right there that's why i put
like two bath bombs in and
you can't see that i get out of the tub
once it starts to dissipate and i'm like
what is that today's episode of
king and the sting is brought to you by
the kratom experts i'm talking about
that super speciosa
that's right if you've never heard of
kratom i stay on it
chin stays on on it uh theo tries to
sniff it from nashville it's a herbal
supplement kind of like cbd but instead
of coming from the cannabis plant
from something close to a coffee tree
people use kratom every day i use it
every day multiple times a day
podcasting stand up whatever i'm doing
i'm on that kratom sun
unlike other guys super speciosa keeps
their kratom
the way nature intended it's pure listen
the kratom game can get dark
the dark arch as theo says not with
super speciosa
not at all if you're going to try kratom
has to be from super speciosa all right
you got to try it out man the other
companies ain't great all right
plus they're for offering you guys i
don't know why my voice crack they're
like a high school kid
plus they're offering you guys 20 off go
to superleaf.com that's
get super leaf.com
enter the promo code kats for 20 off
that's getsuperleaf.com promo code
k-a-t-s this guy's got another debate
club uh
his it's pretty easy but he's quite the
character so i want to play his video
what up what up brendan and theo it's
your boy troy walls coming to you from
nashville tennessee
theo my neighbor you should have been
here in the 90s
your haircut wouldn't have been that
unique you couldn't throw a rock in any
direction without catching a
a mullet or a bolo tie anyways got a
debate club for you
i'm on the road i'm in the steel
industry i'm in sales yep
are you using that apple maps that
google maps
or that waze also shout to the culture
corner
my boy chappelle that rancid shirt
straight
fire get tim armstrong on the podcast
pronto let's go uh let's go also cat
cynthia back with a pair of them gym
socks for your boy when he comes
back home i like this guy gang gang
buzz buzz sniff sniff yep
honk honk baby sniffing that danger the
devil's standing
yeah that's already one round man he'll
sell the [ __ ] out of the house
hopefully he's a politician theo fired
the culture corner for smelling funny
no i didn't but chin what do white
people smell like dude tell us honestly
bro quit [ __ ] beating around the bush
is it like a musky kind of smell see
is that is that so it's not stinky but
musky like what do you mean like an
older sofa kind of yeah yeah like old
furniture
no that's not good like an old rug
you're hanging around the wrong white
people man
are you cleaning yes it's us brendan on
your sofa if you think about how dirty
you're
so that's why sofas get like that yeah
it's one of those things you don't think
oh i got to wipe down this sofa
what what was his debate club uh waze
google maps apple
maps not waze waze is [ __ ] stressful
man this isn't [ __ ] grand theft auto
every time i want to run to the store
and avoid some traffic yeah
waze will take you through a funeral
it'd be like ralph is dead in two miles
what the [ __ ] why are we even going this
way
i just use the though whatever the map
the regular maps is on my phone
is that apple that's apple i noticed
with waze though so i
always know when other people are using
waze because like you're going you head
into a certain place and you make it
like a turn that you go i would never
make this turn and there's a bunch and
there's like three people making that
yeah
and we're going to look at each other
but you know put up the w's way you know
what i mean
waves turn i know what you're doing
right so it's not necessarily a secret
but
i don't know i think i like i think
google's the best
yeah marriage is not working out in 40
feet it's always like what the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] seemed real
personal you know it's exhausting oh he
tells you where to donate
blood and where to get rv's yelp reviews
and youtube comments
but the people are like accent or cop 10
10 10
10 minutes ahead and [ __ ] like i do like
that's weird i like it yeah have you
ever done it though like yeah hey
everybody
i feel like i'm being a part of the
community oh wow
i'm proud of you like if i drive it says
you leave yelp reviews no no but if it
says i
there's a cop right here you bet you i'm
[ __ ]
i'm putting that out i'm like yeah here
the car the pig is right here
yeah it's real y'all y'all look out
because he's right here
yeah yep good for you it's helpful
you're a good person all right
wait what was this guy asking oh but
here's what i don't like is the one
where you
sometimes you click on it and it takes
you to the one it looks like the view is
from like outer space what the [ __ ] is
that one bro that's the one that really
scares me
yeah i like to get i like get high and
tight with it yeah is that
is that apple the one that does it from
basically mars
uh you can use like a top down view or
like
your perspective either one or hybrid
google google has like the google earth
where you can see everything too
i just use the apple one man keep it
easy just whatever is easy like what is
it straight
up to your phone whatever hooks up
whatever hooks up to the car yeah but
they both
you get google or the other sometimes
apple don't know where [ __ ] is though
well sometimes i'll do apple and then
i'll look up google and google has like
the better shortcut that's what no
like how do you know i'm saying your
[ __ ] i'm saying google can find stuff
that apple can't
even if you go certain like like you
know how you know do it like this
ask siri something and then ask google
something yeah and you'll find that
google has more options
series like limited it's almost like
they sometimes should be like what car
are you in
uh you know how tough are you because
it's taking me down when i was trying to
get downtown man
i went down seedy area it feels ask him
do you want to be near black people
yeah are you looking for help
guys how urban do you want to get yeah
you do you want to avoid urban
neighborhoods
it's like are you willing to take which
actually ain't a bad option it's not
bad i'll go frederick douglass i have
but i'm not going mlk junior boulevard
you know what i'm saying so i do kind of
make certain choices you know
um every mlk boulevard isn't a bad name
let's avoid that man i don't understand
that
dude i have a dream that there is an
alternate route
um what about this though do you uh do
you remember
before they had the google maps and [ __ ]
eric what
what yeah first map question was the
first one
remember math questions you had to print
that [ __ ] off and take it but you don't
know how excited though because before
that it was the
thomas guy and that thomas guy was so
confusing
so you had to that's just l.a like a
book you had to have a table top book
you know in your card to figure out
where to go so then when matt case
mapquest came out i thought i was so
cool cause i'm like oh [ __ ]
i got it right here make a left at this
corner
but then now man can you even imagine i
can't even
you can't even explain that to kids you
know what's weird is when you go to rent
a car now they go do you want the
the do you want the navigation [ __ ] you
have a phone
oh don't even it's 20 21. they they just
that's for idiots yeah that's right it's
like people that buy
a hotel porn yeah yeah
if you're still buying hotel porn you
you getting the [ __ ] yeah uh you know
what
give me the gps and i'll take the gps
put the thought gps in on the rentals
like you have damn fool
what are you talking about all right we
got one more debate club
i don't know if you guys heard but at
one of uncle joey's show somebody tried
to attack him with the knife
and his opener came and took the guy out
i sent nick the video
so it brings up a debate club if you
guys go on the road
and you can have one comic to have your
back who's it going to be
gang gang buzz buzz i don't know if this
was true because i didn't hear about it
anyplace else but there was a tic tac
that went viral
oh come on dude who you gonna pick daddy
oh um
i thought i need to see your record
first
this is it right here
ask gonzaga legends legend
um i would probably pick big easy over
there brenda shaw man that's who i got
to pick what was your nickname in
fighting brendan
uh it was big brown but before that was
the hybrid
but it's big brown for the last like
four years thanks to brian
i would say big brown man i would take
big brown probably as my hit man joe
rogans maybe with that specialty
leg chop he's got or i would take andrew
dice clay also because andrew dice clay
would probably try to help and then get
his [ __ ] ass because that guy
and then you and then you can get away
while they're beating them
yeah while they're beating some old man
dressed like oscar the grouch i can
[ __ ] sneak off
yeah my thing is like i'm not
i just i'm just who wants to fight like
you know i'm sure you're in a position
where you don't want to fight anymore
but dawg
this ain't about that eric i don't know
if i can hear him because he would try
to avoid the fight
i'd avoid all costs but if it came down
to it somebody can put the [ __ ] sleep
don't know about how many times have
somebody okay but i bet this happens to
you a lot you're out with your boys
whatever
i know what you're gonna say and
everybody's having somebody might be
like you don't want to mess with us
because big brown's here
[Laughter]
get out there big brown get ahead of
this the only time that i thought i was
gonna have to use my old skills dust off
the old skills
is when mark maron was on stage in the
main room and these two dudes from
australia kept heckling him
and he went hard on him right and just
lit him on [ __ ] fire
and the mark goes ah [ __ ] man i gotta
walk to my car
he's like come on he's like be cool and
they kept talking [ __ ] to him
and you know the security at the comedy
store god bless what security
but they're the guys that work there
yeah they're not really seeking security
you know but they're not and they're not
exactly in shape so i stood there it's
ari mantis
yeah it's kind of ari madness and you
know
and derek posted you're so sad yeah
that's it
i'm like oh so you know it's it's these
comics so i i hung out because i want to
make sure mark
was all right two times first of all i'm
not a fighter
i'm a big guy right so when you're a big
guy people avoid trying to fight you yep
but it don't mean i can fight
like you know and i'm just not a fighter
and i'm in my life now
i got more to lose i'm calling the
authorities we're not getting into a
fight you know i'm not starting to fight
with you
i mean if i need to throw some hands
i'll do whatever i can i always say you
better kill me because i'm not gonna
stop
you know what i mean yeah but like i've
never so two times this has happened one
time al madrigal was on stage at the
comedy store
and he was going in on this dude all
right
and then afterwards al he gets off stage
and he walks to the
uh or box office right and
i see the dude beeline into al right
so i i just walked in front of the guy
and stood in front of
so you're out yeah he came here the
guy's back here
and i'm just like good set man you did
good boom boom boom boom then the guy
just kind of like
left then i looked at me he goes thank
you
but but i'm thinking to myself oh god
please don't die i don't want either
with marx saying something
please don't make me do something man
yeah i don't get in trouble
yeah so i want to protect the comics
another time i'm at the laugh factory
and dane cooks on stage
and dane is going in on these guys
you know but they were like this guy
stands up and it's about to be a thing
and i found myself
walked walking over there but as i was
doing that i thought what am i going to
do you know what i mean
but like that's just my instinct it's
like when you see one of your
brethren on stage no matter who they are
like them or not or whatever even if
they deserve it
bro there's a feeling of like i got to
step in and do something yeah i gotta
let i don't know i'd let some people get
lit up i think
i'd probably let marc maron get lit up
i'll let some people get lit not mark
come on man
sometimes people need a smackdown
i'm
don't do that [ __ ] again sometimes
people need a little bit of help
hey yeah be cool man yeah that's it i'll
tell you this how gangster brian callum
is this is the closest i've ever been
getting in a fight on the street is uh
me and brian were somewhere in the
valley at this
bar for this random bar brian wanted me
to meet him for a drink
so we sit down there and all these
hell's angels walk in
man they got all their best on stuff
like that and the real big one who's
probably they're you know they're the
the meat of the group kept staring at me
they recognize me
and you see them talking them because
usually they want to show how tough they
are i told brian like dog we gotta
figure a way to get the [ __ ] out he's
like why
i was like i heard them man they're
gonna start [ __ ] with us and come
over here
and brian was like let him come over
here i was like here we go
what yeah brian was like let him come
over they can do [ __ ] man i'm like
what if they do though i'm like let's
get the [ __ ] out he's like well if they
do i ain't going nowhere
okay first of all
that kind of [ __ ] never happens to me
you know why
because i'm never going to a bar in the
valley we're in the valley
well that is what's happening where
hell's angels might come by
you mean neither this is brian callan's
call man yeah you should you didn't know
by when you walked in and it was like
no it's kind of like one of those it was
all swinging doors you know
[Laughter]
but look also man you gotta know man a
lot of motorcyclists if you give them a
couple years they die in car accidents
bro
is that the truth it's not even worth
fighting them dude
or they become teamsters on in their own
sets
[Laughter]
that's where i see them all why would
this guy try stabbing joey
yeah have we ever seen this video uh it
went viral on tic tac and actually
sean who's listening in theo's studio
sent some more information but here's
the is it in jersey
let's see
traps
but then this guy tweeted when the thing
went viral i guess this was a couple
years ago he said okay i'm the comic
from this video i did tackle and choke
out a drunk dude
joey diaz show it happened a couple of
years ago he was hitting audience
members and staff i never saw a knife
he never went after joey also i take a
bullet for uncle joey yeah
so yeah but this is like popping off on
ins uh tic tac it's got like over a
million views
but you know you're out here on the road
i mean theo you know before you were
theo
you know you were doing a lot of [ __ ]
gigs you know
you're you know i'm still doing [ __ ]
gigs you know you're dying no no no no
dude i was out in
i was out yeah yeah yeah i picked this
up i was out at like
i was in tennessee actually at some no
kentucky
i think i could take this club yeah you
know you're out at these places and when
you're
a man you're out and you're by yourself
you don't even realize like i'm at a
hotel by myself i don't know the opener
i didn't bring anybody
i mean i'm just getting the local guy
and i'm on stage and this woman just
you know she starts going in she goes
crazy you know what did she say do you
remember eric
i i don't remember she just was going
i'm already done with my set
probably something you've said before
theo you know and then
she like um so she starts acting up big
time
stands up so i pulled out my phone which
was the mistake because i cued
everybody to pull out there yeah so i
started recording her now as i'm
recording her
she swings at the phone now from the
back
it looks like she swung and tried to hit
me so that's the thing that tmz
picked up i get an email eric we're
running with this story how this heckler
hit you and i'm like oh my god
you know what i mean but that's not what
happened have you had any scare still on
the road like i've had i've had
i think i was somewhere in texas
yeah i think texas we had a bomb threat
so there's like tons of security around
but i was like man
just more people get blown up dude the
first time i i remember when i uh first
time i do
doing comedy i'm doing i'm in montana
doing triple runs
and i'm way out in like miles montana
and again i'm
it's just me and this i'm not i'm the
opener and this like
guy's the headliner and he's like he's a
white guy and
and you know the the crowd is all white
they're rowdy we're in a bar where
there's like you know pool tables and
you know you know what i mean it's a
rowdy ass bar guy comes up to me
afterwards he's like
you want to fight you know and i'm like
not really
why you know what i mean like no how
many rounds did he want to go though
dude good question at this point i'm
looking around like how am i going to
get back to my hotel this is this guy's
town
you know what i mean like these people
know each other right yeah i don't give
a [ __ ] i try to avoid i go like yeah
where you from man you know yeah i'm
from new york you know
i'm going to this is exactly what he
said to me word for word i said well
what are you doing here he goes
to get away from the [ __ ] oh
that's his exactly i said it plural so
he meant more than one
yeah you put an s on it theo
but a hard er it sounds like hard er so
i said to him
i went like this well you did it
you did it great job and then it sounds
like you're at a kid rock party
dude yeah
then he just i wasn't gonna bite on it
you know cause i thought like once yeah
yeah so then i went and then i told the
oh the headline i was like yo man i
gotta tell you this funny thing that
just happened because
it's weird it's like you're being racist
in this day and age you don't even make
any sense right you know
so he gets mad where is he what oh i'm
like what are you getting mad about what
are we gonna do you're gonna go over
there
where's this guy at yeah i said
so i've experienced these moments where
i feel like damn
what what am i gonna you know what what
would you do you know yeah i mean for
you
you guys you know have you ever done
neil's got an entourage now he's got
uh you know yeah camera crew with him
yeah yeah yeah
alright man this has this dark arch he's
gonna shank somebody
look i gotta tell you bloated [ __ ] boys
i paid the cost to be the boss okay i
gotta tell you that straight up man
loaded [ __ ] what what i'm also telling
you guys
sorry i want to see you without that
camouflage on we know what you hide
that was a typo man as a typo you all
heard
uh uh all i'm saying is yeah man look i
think things happen everywhere man i
think a lot of times there's dudes that
want to step to people and they'll use
whatever
elements they can you know like and i've
had people call me the n word i've had
people call me uh
f word [ __ ] um i've had people call me
just all you know people
anytime somebody wants to start [ __ ]
they're gonna come at you especially and
they know also i think they know a
comedian is by themselves
you know so there's not much that they
can do you know
um but i think also the vibe has changed
over time i think and it does get better
as your career goes along because
you get in places where there's a little
bit better you know there's better
security at like an improv
and there's better like you know there's
at least a people that have to come and
pay for a ticket
than somebody who can just roll up and
walk in and just get wasted knowing that
they're looking for [ __ ] but there's a
lot of
i'm telling there's a lot of comedy
clubs in the country where they don't
necessarily have security or even think
about it
i mean how many times have you like
started like a heckler starts in they're
too drunk and then i start to look
around like
oh they're actually not going to kick
this guy out yeah because he's at a
table of seven they haven't paid their
bills they don't know yeah they don't
know what's going on it's like a
business
there's nothing you just start to go
well damn this is actually a dangerous
situation
the club owner will sell you out the
club owner if it's a big party
and they're raising hell they won't
throw them out yup that's not that
matter what that is
in the comedy store in la jolla and
totally different
different but derek poston was doing uh
he had some joke
about white people and this like group
of 12 older white people
yelled out nazi and throw uh they threw
uh wine glasses at them
and they kicked them out fast well yeah
you also can call it a police
yeah you know you're just weird you know
he yelled
nazis i call the cops dude if i see two
handicapped people making out i [ __ ]
call the cops bro i did that in new
orleans
what is the justification for that like
what do you call that when you call in
what do you say
i say look i say suspicious i'm trying
to do well just say
the odds of us getting another
handicapped person are increasing and i
would show up at the corner of [ __ ]
claiborne and
uh and magnolia i love that he doubled
down
how is that happening like it's not easy
for two people like do they have helpers
do they have an army manis there with
them that's gonna like
figuring it out like how did two people
like how did two handicapped people go
on like a date and how does it they got
gps
right i want to turn it off you've never
seen love on the spectrum
yeah their own ways that is different
that's i'm talking about like
fans you know both guys fans and like
one guy
at the end of that it's like this
[Applause]
you know it comes down off the van and
the other one is like
no he's like i'm coming for you girl
girl you look fine as [ __ ] yeah yeah
like that would be a whole like
that would be dope i'm just trying to
say i would be envious because i'd be
like damn y'all really
because that you committed like it's one
you don't turn them back
it's one thing to be like all right you
know i don't know if i really want to be
with this person
but after you have to get in the van you
gotta
you gotta get your chair
it's like prom every night for them you
feel me you know you got to get to the
elevator because you got to go through
that thing you know what to make of
their stairs
it's a lot so by the time they get there
they're like
hopefully we finishing this
yeah the more you go through man i think
the more you go through the more love is
at the end of the line you know that
yeah there you go that's beautiful
that's what i'm saying there you go he's
gonna call the cops on you though but
yeah he's waiting
yeah that's such a [ __ ] up man i'm
just trying to get eric to be brave
enough to darken up a little bro you
know
because we can't
he on the lawn talking about this
handicapped people [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i didn't just [ __ ] i said kissing him
like excuse me
i said there's handicap people [ __ ]
and i don't like it i don't like it
and there's a chance they're gonna make
more handicap like i don't know if it
works like that sir
you know like that whole conversation
called actually an emergency
yeah i don't know if it's contagious
like that's her i'm just saying you
gotta freaking think ahead man we gotta
think big picture though are you right
doug
that's theo yeah that's theo right there
karen bonds look like karen
name the there's your title for the
episode
uh this we'll close out with some uh
culture corner auditions next week we're
gonna have either someone either on zoom
or in studio
um but we'll start off with this guy
getting those two uh non-keto twins in
here we'll we'll see if we can we'll see
if we can
uh this guy i think eric met at a bar
one time
i was thinking he's the guy who said the
n-word
you'll hear more about them and it it'll
make sense what's up tio brendan coulter
corner chappelle cat it's your one and
only bosnian homie
dino christian daltovich i am from
bosnia bosnia refugee but i ain't got no
accident at the man i'm uh
just [ __ ] with you guys but yeah man
i'm a truck driver out here
came here 95. after the genocide the war
in bosnia
damn uh been through some [ __ ] man been
through prison
uh done some dumb [ __ ] yeah
all that type of jazz you know all that
says the story all that stuff man
but yeah man i feel like i can add a
good addition to the culture corner
[ __ ] yeah i'm uh
pretty normal guy man i like to write
poem
rapping hippie hop don't stop you don't
drop
whatever you know [ __ ] yeah man
i attached a rapper video to this man i
don't really know oh
there's a white rapper wow
and brendan this guy's bosnia and not
white i feel
i feel like that guy's in witness
protection yeah
and he doesn't realize that this is
going on the internet yeah
and like his like witness protection
agent is at home right now going what
the [ __ ]
is that he did what idiot doing
what if he's in whitney's protection
program
you got to be an animal yeah whitney
cummings has a protection program
service
uh here's his rap lately i've been
praying to the one above
i think i've done too many drugs got me
[ __ ] up and i ain't never scared to
die and i never was
and when i go i just hope i don't done
enough for my kid's sake
so when the road got rough i had to
buckle up yeah this life could get tough
you gotta suck it up
you can't be spending your money you
gotta run it up keep chasing women and
you'll end up looking dumb as [ __ ]
i'm saying look i know what i speak
before i represent you
i know what it feels like to toss
eternity to sleep and to make matters
worse you always slept in a week but
you gotta learn to keep your faith cause
if god gotta say you won't be okay stay
on the grind their day stacking freedom
lays
get the devil out your face you won't
seem straight yeah
that's probably the one thing i could
promise put it on my kids even swear to
my mama
unlike the day i swore to your honor
cause i ain't telling [ __ ] to your honor
i got
honor damn
praise christ baby praise god
you know what it wasn't terrible it
wasn't bad it wasn't bad at all
i'm not i'm not mad at him you know what
i mean but he's just out here and
driving these streets did he say he's in
la nick
uh no he was like south florida or
something but he's a trucker so he's all
yeah he's all over the country
and drive over here that's your
demographic that would be pretty intense
i think he'd be cool
then bosnians dude and i'll tell you
about the bosnians bro a lot of them
just died a lot of them died and you
know about it brenda you don't
a little bit doubt that
tell him nick tell him nick i'm looking
up bosnia and genocide right now here we
go
jesus christ it's a crack crack staff
you got here
8300 killed yeah yeah the bosnians have
been through a lot dude i don't know why
people don't like them i haven't met
enough of them to know why people don't
like them yet i like that guy
well we got justin long right here his
new podcast isn't going well
character uh it's justin long dude he
has a new podcast that isn't going well
[Laughter]
let me tell you why i should be the next
guest
on the culture corner name ivan diaz and
vicus
six two tall glass of water peak of my
existence
mexican i know who pancho villa is i
know who richie valens is selena
got posters of her all over my walls yes
i do have a friend named hector to be
precise
for american core values bro
i gotta love apple pie my parents are
divorced didn't do great in school
can't name all the states on the map but
i can tell you what a neutral zone
infraction is
make me your next guest
and this is the liam witness protections
it looks like kirsten bryant baby unique
clown baby so it can't be any worse than
baby
and baby you need a damn lizard owner
too yeah she brought a [ __ ] snake
this guy was cool though i dig this dude
no you don't dude
i think the white rapper was fun nah huh
you didn't like him yeah i liked him but
i just want you to be honest with
everybody i want you to be honest with
eric too
uh i think both of these guys could be
fun
yeah you're right you're right you're
right man they're both good
guys no look i'm happy that this guy
sent this in this guy's obviously from
another country
and he you know who knows even what it's
like over there
and so the fact that he's being able to
get this put together and send this out
he had that how that soft helmet on um
i would have done a crystalline
impersonation i would have went with a
crystalline impersonation that's what i
would have went with
yeah that'll get you on the show so how
about this here's what i would like to
request out of this young man
we would like to see a crystalline
impersonation if you can do that and
send it in i think that that would
really be interesting brendan what do
you think yeah that'd be fun
there you go sweet and we got one more
uh this guy's uh he went a little long
but he was good let me know if you want
me to cut him off
why does he get cut off he went over he
went over
he's from wisconsin [ __ ] truck
driving in bosnia
he was here he had two videos had a rap
the one black guy he's like this one
went a little long so it's about two
what is he what did he
let's have somebody of color two minutes
is an eternity this even has a filter on
it
let's see this guy what up we even put a
filter too he looked a little lighter in
the original video
i see
it's my initials
i am a black as you can see a lot of
culture going on here
a lot of culture going on here uh
but i am a black from louisville
kentucky okay
i like country music
i'm one of the miami's you know got a
tight three to five
i played a little bit of college
football okay
on the lower level oh he's right on you
on a lower level
train a little bit of mma
i watch a little bit of porn
amen brother praise god we all suffer
and my father is a pastor
who wants me to follow in his footsteps
hates that i do mma i mean how's this
guy different than chappelle but he has
a dad
that's
it's not even that it's long like he got
enough pauses
that field can step in each baby
[Laughter]
the lord works well you know praise god
salaam alaikum my brother we all like
like this
this guy's perfect for theo he can just
chime in with i love your hair
you know just in between this is a lot i
love right i love red tails remember
that movie red tails
[Laughter]
come on man you go don't roast red tails
come on it's pretty good man
but i'm just saying it seemed outlandish
but it was good
um look obviously this guy is a talented
gentleman
um i think we need to i i think we need
to ask him to do something though b
i think have him you know like just like
with the other guys have him create
something that makes it a little bit
more of a vibe do
one of the things that he said yeah i
would also maybe drink a monster energy
drink for a little more energy yeah yeah
do something coffee something it's easy
to get five minutes when you're silent
half the time
yeah well he only has to say two
sentences in that five minutes
yeah i see what you're doing there slow
talker i like it yeah
he reminds me of glenn big baby davis a
little bit
a little bit do you get glenn big baby
davis in the culture corner
and his things he was uh
he was all excited about the fights he's
a big he's a louisiana guy so
that makes sense we on top right
it's now up here man all right oh [ __ ] i
gave that thousand dollars
uh one guy who had a really cool he's a
pretty artistic guy
i bet you he's white king wow
she the bill died
oh and the other guy they were like oh
next up we got this sleepy guy who just
may not have
who made it probably want me to cut this
one off yeah i'm just gonna throw us in
there anyway i'll let you guys decide
cause it's good this guy may not have
legitimate paperwork
nick and cat oh he's high super big time
fan here
long time listener i actually saw
brennan
uh brian callan and chappelle i stand up
live in phoenix
that's where i'm currently living right
now doing all this art
but i got a king interstinger for you
today guys
what do you think about boys that aren't
even though i'm straight what do you
guys think about getting creative on a
friday night
getting creative on the weekdays
i stay busy painting um but king of
stinging maybe getting your girl
together
doing a little bit of finger painting
here's my favorite one actually
or maybe just solo get the kratom
flowing and get the paints out
king of the sticker for you guys
painting getting artistic
love you guys i even make my own hats
it's smoky joe paint co
painting on clothes painting on canvases
painting on bodies
thank you guys do a commercial yeah a
whole promo
i guess a pro we getting a kickback i
agree he's talented
individual by the way yeah i uh like all
that was great like
i see like he really show like his
personality doesn't match
all that he's showing so i bet you he's
not really like this
what he's doing right now i think he's
playing that up because he because
probably his friends are always getting
on his case about it
yeah you in there doing that bitch-ass
art but he really wants to [ __ ]
talented he's very talented [ __ ] painter
king of the sting piece
we need a new center piece for the
studio i mean that's what he should be
showing
the video was like and i got this for
you guys yeah it's theo and the white
turtleneck my thick ass in the corner
and who's that is that ryan what's his
name that guy that does all the clips
no that was adam ray shackler
yeah that's what's on thing you know
that could be adam right maybe that
rodriguez fella
it does look like adam ray a little
doesn't it right doesn't it
now chin what are you doing are you
still alive i can't even believe that
you're here what's going on
and this guy reminds me of seth green a
little bit a little bit yeah yeah same
vibe
cadence yeah oh no you don't know you
know
i tell you what now i got it in my head
do you guys remember you ever
did you remember clueless yeah remember
the skateboard high guy in clueless
yeah yeah that's this guy right yeah
he reminds me of jamie kennedy a little
bit i can see that
not really actually you don't think so
like jamie kennedy
now though i don't see it there he is
thank you
look at this guy very good there he is
right there that's the same
they're the same guy look at that look
at him
college movie is it road trip yeah with
tom green
and he was in uh ocean 13. is this the
same guy he was the
hockey guy in the teenage mutant ninja
turtles movie no you're saying you have
casey
oh yeah different guy he's in every
movie is that uh
uh gill um
what's that guy's name gila
burns no he was in wine that movie about
wine remember that movie about wine
oh you're thinking of uh sideways
yes great movie not him
who is that gary no guilt
hayden and something and the other one's
uh scott hayden brendan
kill somebody this guy's name is brecken
aaron meyer
yeah people say he looked like uh bill
maher too like a young bill maher
i don't see that and so
yeah right that guy yeah i could see him
looking like a young bill maher yeah
this guy is uh get uh
gill
look at the crackers
and then thomas hayden that's what i'm
thinking about
wait what are you kidding me
a little bit in the face no hell no
younger this guy's younger my bad
that's it that's it
look at the face zoom in the face zoom
in the face zoom in the face they don't
look anything else
well if nick was doom in the face he's
looking at words still you're wasting
everybody's life
yeah that's a bad pitch you could have
picked any one
[Laughter]
there you go i mean i guess they're two
white males
yeah you got that i don't see i got no
hair one has hair
i just i don't get it whatever you guys
are [ __ ] you guys aren't artistic
that's your problem
[Laughter]
it sounds like you are autistic
well then call the cops dawg
yeah any time i'll see you
i'd be like hey two autistic guys have a
show together i need the police over
here that's what i would say
well mr griffin thanks for coming man
yeah you crushed it griffin what are you
doing on twitch too i want to know more
about it so i've never done twitch even
so tell me a little bit more about it
because i know you game a lot yeah i'm
getting error griffin gaming you can
check me out i'm on there daily i'm just
because i don't like going out how's it
going well there's nowhere to go out
there's nowhere to go out so
i just i just game all the time i'm
building up my community and i've gotten
a lot of opportunities because of gaming
like i played video games with t-pain on
a show
you know does he do the voice like no he
doesn't he had this
but i have my thing and i did it you
know it's probably annoying so yeah
you know what i mean it's like when
somebody does a joke to a comic but yeah
i've had like a bunch of
different uh opportunities i did just um
i did this show on the crown channel
on the twitch crown channel during it
was called potluck during the
december what game holiday thing i play
a lot of call of duty
oh wow that's my game little i love i
love playing warzone
so you'll see me in verdansk every
single day on eric griffin gaming
so come check me out wherever the camera
is okay we'll put all that we'll put
that information too and stuff if
is there links people can get to it yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's just twitch
we'll put that in there do they have
treaties on call of duty is it just
fighting or you can do treaties and
stuff as well
is there teams treaties like what kind
of boring ass game
i don't i don't know how to work with
this either i don't want to play where
you're like
sitting at a table and you guys have to
discuss foreign policy
what kind of dumbass game would that be
theo
brendan thought i said treats that's
what his [ __ ] problem is right
brit is picturing two dudes from
different countries making [ __ ]
cinnamon apple pretzels over here that's
his problem
but no there's no way to have a network
there's no way to have peace between the
different people
in the game no it's teams or you're by
yourself killing people no you uh
you could like i do a lot of solo then
but then i have my buddies come in and
we play like you know duos trios or
quads
i've been asking this i've been telling
theo to come jump on with me many times
but yeah
you're too busy out here in these
streets i can't get my thing to work my
controller won't charge right
is my biggest issue but i got to sound
like somebody's grandpa
what what you know what i mean what
system do you play on damn controller
you know but it's cross-platform so you
could play on a pc
uh uh what system does he play on this
ps4
sounds like a [ __ ] old duet system
bro
i don't know yeah
all right doug have fun kids
my bad man oh the series let's start
finish bro i don't have anything else to
do brothers don't [ __ ] finish now
man i gotta get going i get on my
[ __ ] kids
uh friday saturday i'm at san martin two
kids brendan
what'd you say you have two kids it's
not that big of a deal
yeah you're right you're right he acted
like it was the partridge family
you got nine kids and like another baby
mama someplace where he got like two
other ones
says the guy who has plants and says a
guy who plays video games all day
hey don't make don't don't get mad at us
because we make good life choices
dude you're the one out there busting
him yeah you gotta [ __ ]
cause your pull-out game is messed up
dude i would love to uh man god i just
can't believe dustin poirier won that
[ __ ] [ __ ] was crazy
dude what about michael chandler though
what about him
what about the bat what do you think was
scarier having to fight dan hooker or
having to do the back flip off the
[ __ ] top of the octagon
i'd say the back flip i can't do no
backflip
the guy did a backflip before the fight
all right he knocked the job out
jumped on top of the cage and did a back
flip onto the mat he's nuts
oh my god what if he's gonna hurt
himself
but now eric what sport say eric say you
have to get out there right
somebody puts a gun to your head and you
got to get out there and actually do a
sport
right what do you do i play basketball
okay i played basketball when i was
younger and more fit
wait you played in high school or
college didn't you i know i played in
high school yeah just high school
i thought i remember seeing a picture
one time and somebody posted of you
playing high school basketball is that
true do you remember that yeah i i
posted that
it's a throwback thursday you [ __ ] it
was awesome i [ __ ] forgot about that
that was did you play a sport what sport
did you play out there
yeah i play basketball dude i play with
some unique people actually you want to
show them the picture nick
yes sir your team looked pretty good
theo that one dude there's no way he was
in high school
you played with david robinson look at
this squad oh we played they had a dude
in our
name bear bear this other dude named
arms johnson
look at this squad arms johnson look at
the dude on the far right
top right come on high school
bro that's don galatis he was 41 years
old dude
he also was the janitor at our school
and went to school
wait first of all that dude on the top
right
like that's what i'm saying he's 37 at
least that's what i'm saying bro it's a
juco transfer
gee whiz that's don gummy baby these are
the only six black people in theo's town
you know what i mean look at the deal
they look scared those are the only
black kids in the whole
city he grew up in look brother on the
basketball
bro they called me pass
they looked like they called you white
chocolate right that was my nickname
baby pass baby look like you and the guy
behind you would get together and talk
[ __ ] about the rest of the way did you
play
like cause like there's six of them so
that was five starters
when did you when did you do the numbers
yeah when did you get it there's six
white guys
only five six black guys i see a tall
cornbread
white boy in the back when did you get
in i see theo being very hydrated and
helping out the boys
yeah yeah i played late at night phil
was all armed back then too look at that
arms and arrows long arm of the law
right there
long arms that's cal jackson right there
that's john clark
you got uh vincent jackson don galatis
jonathan smith
and you got [ __ ] james uh
i don't know he worked at the auto body
shop
he didn't even go to high school they
just said bro he wasn't in school he
didn't even they didn't check
this [ __ ] didn't even go to
school he just showed up for the game
ball yeah and this was junior high i
know
his overalls when he got to the
what this was middle school i think
that was no it wasn't there's no way
never eight and 14 or middle school you
can't be middle school 14 looks like
that dude number eight got two kids in
this picture
you know what i mean i'm ready helps get
going two because of kids
yeah he he after the game he like after
this picture he was like look i got two
kids
i gotta go i gotta get going and phil
was talking [ __ ] back then
yeah oh man these are the days bro
uh eric thanks so much for joining us
man yeah any time guys
yeah man that was fun thanks we
appreciate it that's it
love you guys theo good to see you
brother get your ass back in l.a
good to see you i'll see you in studio
next week brother all right brother
later
all right peace peace eric brennan and
theo fighter and wait i gotta go in and
go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
hate on me i do not mind theo looking
like the type of dude they got a pack of
matches in his pockets at all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
trapping couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
king and a sting king and a stink oh
yeah
king
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you